[Music]
welcome back to careful boys everybody
we are the most careful of all the boys
in the world all the time
all in one place
we have with us today mr tj lee
and we also have pilot mike over at the
the big boy table
and if you guys might be wondering
tj
might be
this is basically the part three of the
saga it would be part three yeah
oh ryan tj's like can we catch them up
and uh fast forward catch
this guy up yeah what's saga so uh i
told a long story about this car
accident that i was in where i had a
friend in the back seat who wasn't
wearing a seat belt when the car went
tumbling down an embankment and uh he
was paralyzed as a result of the
accident
had a 13 chance of
any improvement
paralyzed from the torso down and here
he is today and it's funny because i
started getting random messages i'm like
what's going on i didn't tell him that i
told the story at all i guess the people
like really just like look through your
stuff and they found me how do they do
it we have great stalkers that are fans
yeah my fans like they're very invasive
imagine they picked the wrong friend
they're like hey man heard about your
situation it's harris
it's hawk
yeah because i didn't i didn't name him
because i just i don't know about like
where i never really like even tell that
story unless it's like a personal
conversation so i was like i don't know
if he wants me to like put it out there
so i just didn't name him but then they
found him anyway so and then i watched
it and i was like
what there's things that you even
haven't told me
yeah there's a spot out there and i was
like so we heard his story uh what from
your perspective like starting from
i guess
either if you're a conscious after the
car rolled down the mountain or on the
road like what is your perspective oh oh
by the way he he blames himself for um
going up there because of the girlfriend
that's the part that i never told him
about oh the first time he ever heard me
did you guys talk about that no he he
hit me up a little bit he was like dude
i didn't know that uh that that's how
you felt about it yeah like it was uh or
yeah just like right after you guys shot
it i was just like what the heck and
then i talked to him about it uh the
funny thing is
prior to going up we were just hella
hype because i just finished college or
it was like the high school it was like
the week before i can go start school
and ryan's like we should do something
should do something see if you've told
yourself online online just like a game
on a game like hey let's do something
yeah let's do something
not knowing girl and then my other
friend had a girl like he wanted to see
up there so i was just like oh guys trip
you would have been like fifth wheel bro
yeah i didn't i didn't know until after
you just wanted to like norcal let's go
i'll drive those can any of you guys
drive stick they're like no i'm like
well all right i'll just i'll drive i'll
drive so
we did our trip we did our thing up
there dropped you off not even not even
close to the bay that was like an hour
and a half outside it's pretty far yeah
we're like stockton or something yeah
where are you kicking it
jackson danville yeah oh yeah
you guys made it to norcal yeah we did
we was on the way back okay it was on
the way back dropped off ryan i went to
go visit my family at sf and they're
like why are you here i was like oh hi
i'm just here i didn't spontaneous guys
i'm just just here chilling and then i'm
gonna go back like tomorrow tonight like
okay
and then all of a sudden the other
friend gets a call he's like oh my
girl's like she's in san jose let's go
i'm like all right let's go so i dropped
him off i come back to the bay and all
of a sudden the other friend's like oh
like i gotta get picked up now it's like
all right copenhagen as soon as i pick
them up
go back to family eat some dinner and
ryan's like hey you gotta come now
oh wait that's right
why did why did i have to come now
because the um because my girl her
parents got home early
and they caught me with her
and they were like get out
and i was like
ryan's out here pulling up his pants all
right
i remember the directions that you told
me like when you get there like park
like two houses yeah i was like she
lives she was neighbors with gary payton
of all [ __ ] people
the [ __ ] glove what just got a little
hotline though i think
you're a huge fan
park next to gary payton's house i'll
come running out that's great let's roll
up he's like all right go go go go go
all right that's the end of the trip as
we're driving down i drove like well
like 20 hours 12 hours oh just something
crazy and then uh i showed my friend how
to
well ryan told me all this crazy story
like well you had a rough day well i'll
we'll drive i'll drive it ryan's about
the wise ideas it seems like it's
[ __ ] worse
oh
[ __ ] tired it's it's not that hard to
drive stick once she gets started true
so i showed it i showed my buddy how to
drive it and i was like hey just give me
like a couple hours and then i should be
good i just need a little quick break
you know we could get there
turns out he drove like most of the way
and then right before all i heard was oh
[ __ ] and then
and then
blacking in and out so you were sleeping
and then you you heard the crash happen
or what happened there like you i just
heard the the driver go oh [ __ ] and then
all i hear is like just like dust and
just just like tumbling were you did you
wake up to it or did were you just kind
of resting i woke up to him saying
because he was so loud
at that moment and then you were in the
back seat he was in the back seat so i
was like it was a two-door uh nissan
sentra yeah
and so i was like laying down so i just
need some rest i just drove for like so
many hours yeah and then
oh [ __ ] and then
when i woke up i was like
what was the first thing that you saw
when you woke up
this is dark cause i was inside the car
yeah so
and i think i was just like hey but i
couldn't really talk i was like hey you
remember saying asking us to like pull
you out yeah i was like hey you guys
good and then did you feel pain did you
i was just numb just numbing cold and
tired but
a lot of people were just tired
fatigued yeah because i didn't sleep and
i was like
hey you guys good all right pull me out
which probably wasn't the smartest no
yeah but you didn't feel your neck at
all huh no so at the time
during the crash uh he had slit his
throat
and uh oh you could kind of see the scar
yeah and it was all just like i was
trying to like
uh stop it i couldn't it was just like
all which he didn't tell me crazy fast
so like recently two couple years back
because i was just like hey i'm just
tired man i just need sleep not knowing
that i'm bleeding out and him not
telling me oh yeah i mean it's a bad
time to tell you yeah i was like i'm
just tired can i go to sleep like no
like talk to me like yeah i just i was
like i just want to go to sleep though
yeah sleepy he just kept saying like
dude i'm tired oh you're cold and sleepy
because you're dying yeah but i didn't
know i was just like oh i don't know
what's going on right just like [ __ ]
she's talking like oh and all of a
sudden like fading in and out
the helicopter gets there that's like
that was the next thing you remember the
helicopter yeah and then and then
they're like hey
like stay awake i'm like huh dude i'm
tired dude like dude
i'm so sleepy fading fast man is that
anyway that's crazy did you could you
see like his face turning blue or
anything like that like it was so dark
all i saw was i mean i could make his
skin apart from his blood and that was
it
like it's just the shades because they
were far apart in the spectrum other
than that it's pitch black there's no
light out there how's your memory
because like trauma is like known to
like bust everybody's memory it's pretty
i mean every now and then i'll just
remember little things here and there
but um
i think for the most part i'm pretty
calm when things get crazy like my
reactive thinking is pretty chill that's
scary bro tj when when ryan went to go
flag someone down do you remember him
leaving you for that moment yeah i just
remember just looking at the stars and
was like
i'm tired i'm tired and also like oh
there's a lot of stars you know we're
producing from the city we're like
mentally
were you mentally alert at that point
like
i guess the i was just groggy so you
didn't feel like i'm [ __ ] up no it's
just kind of like this i'm cold well
being so cold and fatigued i was like oh
i can't move
all right
you didn't feel any type of like
shock or stiffness because i got a car
accident too where were like our cars
spun and then it hit a light post and
once it hit the light post like i was
out but then when i woke up i just
remember my body like being so [ __ ]
stiff and molded in a way
that i never felt before and i almost
had to like like crunch and flex my way
out but he was he was also paralyzed so
when he says he doesn't feel something
yeah it was just like he was already
paralyzed that's like the way i bounced
around like a ping pong ball oh my god
it's like i could look back at it now
and like just laugh because so the funny
thing is say if i was like sitting up in
the seat belt everyone's always like why
were you laying down
i'm like if i had a sod i'd just been
crushed like a sleep instead of soda
can't cause if you look at the car when
we went to the junkyard and finally got
it back it was like a can
so was it actually lucky that you were
laying down flat and you guys were good
yeah well yeah for the most part the
driver was like totally good uh you're a
sitting shotgun yeah i just the main
thing that [ __ ] me up was just the
airbag yeah because airbags destroy you
yeah yeah yeah i've had an airbag
explode my face i hurt so bad yeah it's
crazy yeah yeah i do remember talking to
the last time but i did try i do
remember like a glimpse moment of trying
to grab on to something and you said
like yeah you're like no grab me you're
still like there you just you reacted
because i was reacting so i'm trying to
grab onto something and you're just like
i think because i didn't have a head
rest on my seat my head was like this i
think you tried to grab me
but all i remember is as we were rolling
but i'll never forget this [ __ ]
visual because i don't think you could
see this anywhere
but when you're rolling in a car
it's getting [ __ ] visibly smaller as
you're just looking at it and it's just
like like a can is crushing around here
yeah it's because like you're going like
this but from your perspective you're
you're like steady camped in the car so
it's like you're on a gimbal basically
just looking at the [ __ ] you're
last week we went on a hike and we saw
like at least three cars that were just
crushed off of the side they just leave
them there yeah because it's it there's
a highway it's right by the hoover dam
and there's a huge highway there and
then i was like wait that's a car and
then there's like an axle on the ground
and you walk a little bit more there's
like three cars stuck and all of them
were crushed whoa because it just
probably cost so much money to lug that
they're just like just leave it there
it's like mountain climbers that just
get frozen in the [ __ ] or go racing
up in the mountains and just leave it
there so do you remember
that kind of do you remember when when
you were finally at the we were in the
hospital together and then we're
separated by this like
curtain
and um i could hear the
everything that you were going through
like i could hear the doctors saying
like okay they were trying to tell you
what they're going to do i don't even
think you were like dude
they're just talking they were there
yeah they were just telling me okay now
we're gonna do this we're gonna they i
remember at one point they said we're
gonna drill holes into your skull
i don't i don't remember
so soldier to hold your [ __ ] remember
this is like that was like my first time
ever in the hospital
so all the information even now as
working in healthcare like there's so
many questions like it's just like going
back like uh-huh uh-huh all right here
was like surgery okay cool uh-huh
they're like not if you uh
your friends are here okay coco like
you're you're you're your family's here
but then i think he said that your
family's here and my mom's there and
that's where i was like oh [ __ ] like now
i'm in trouble yeah i'm in trouble
because we're still like 18 or 18 at the
time i'm in trouble i didn't even tell
her
oh damn so it doesn't matter if i'm
paralyzed gonna whoop my ass down
yeah you remember
the moment from the crash getting
put in the helicopter going to the host
do you remember any of that stuff i
remember from
the
emt come in like glimpses and then
helicopter i was like oh it's cold it's
extra cold and it's like ah i can't open
my eyes oh and then there's a guy there
was the guy that put me in and he was
just like
all right just i think just trying to
keep me awake like name information
address uh
allergies this and i was like you really
want to know my allergies
i'm allergic to cats that's all i know
is like okay you get that cat out of
there
did you remember that at one point
when when you were laying there they put
it they threw a sheet over you because
you were cold but from our perspective
it looked like you were [ __ ] dead i
think i think when it did that i was
just like i got a little like warmth i
was just like
this is nice trying to just go to sleep
again yeah but dying really
i didn't know that you were alive until
we got to the hospital like until they
took me in the ambulance and i was in
the room and they were like oh your
friend's right there i was like i
thought he was dead because you guys did
the whole thing from the [ __ ] movies
because yeah because you guys you guys
got ambulance that got flown right yeah
well i didn't even know that they didn't
tell me that then you got flown first
class that's sick man
air force one
do you remember they put this
frame it looked like a box and it's like
like a it was a bunch of metal and it
was connected to your head
like inside well it was like an extern
like an exoskeleton called a halo yeah
but it's not in your bone it's in the
bone yeah because i've seen someone like
arms and stuff not maybe not a head but
similar where it's like in the bone but
it's out the bone you're like oh my god
how does that even regina george and uh
mean girls yeah yeah same exact setup
and then didn't they do something to
your teeth oh yeah they freaking put the
they like knocked your teeth out so the
funniest thing so i don't remember them
putting that on because there's like a
lot of stuff going on i'm just kind of
like looking at the bright light
uh i saw i kind of saw you guys pass by
and then saw my mom and i was like so
sorry holy [ __ ] and then like he said go
to surgery like cold cold like cool like
uh the crazy thing is
the time that happened was the only like
the the doctor
he was staying extra like just over time
just for no reason so like the timing of
it was like oh we could get you into
surgery now because this guy's a
specialist
so went in
surgery and they're like count from 10
i'm like all right ten
nine
i woke up like oh [ __ ]
i was supposed to come down from ten and
then does the surgery was already done i
can't move
there's like a thing so i was like
counting in my head and then i'm like
like
in the dark in the room just like
looking i know okay cool i can't look
what the [ __ ] did they do to my teeth
say so were you like eight
seven six and you're like wait a minute
they finished ten i went from ten to
eight which is funny because i had
another surgery before and i was like
i'm gonna get to like seven this time
it's like it's so funny wake up i'm like
like first i was like coughing because
it's like there's a tube down my throat
i'm like oh my god can you feel it on
the inside oh that was like the most
horrible feeling so like it's like
during covet they said oh that's what
you need i was like hell no
i'm not going back again i'm not going i
know how that feels like they like
busted the tooth and that's all i'm
feeling my like
why the why would they do that and then
also i was like
kink yeah no no one came to doctor
it's like looking around there's no one
in there and i was like well i need to
figure out just what happened and the
only thing in my mind was if this is an
air tube
i should if i if it if i close it and it
beeps someone will come
oh
so for like a good like 30 minutes i'm
like i'm just slowly gnawing at this
tube and then i finally like get there
and it beeps the nurse comes in super
fast like are you oh i'm like i could i
could breathe or i thought i could
breathe because later i found out my
lungs collapsed but i was like
okay cool like they take it out like oh
i'm like all right cool like
as soon as that happen like knock their
teeth out for nothing
i don't know they probably had to at
some point yeah yeah well later on my
lungs they told me like one of my lungs
collapsed
so it was like i guess not for nothing i
guess it was keeping me alive but just
like i felt like i could breathe because
i was like what was the injury actually
to your spine uh c4 c5 they said just
compact it really hard so all the nerves
just kind of just like kind of sever
semi-severe so it's like an incomplete
surgery so incomplete means it didn't
fully sever but they don't know what's
going to happen and then like another
part of my cervical spine just got like
crushed so like
just like oh like two three four two
three four five or uh that's like a
whole section so it's like really high
up because my head just got what was the
recovery process like like were you
paralyzed like what was the first thing
that you gained function or feeling uh
the recovery well i didn't even move for
like
four months even when you visited me and
i was like
when did you realize you were first
paralyzed and how did you deal with it i
think once i woke up i'm like oh this is
kind of real from like ten nine so you
didn't know until you started counting i
didn't know what was really going on
because still like kid never seen
anything never been in hospital probably
pumped full of drugs
oh yeah yeah you didn't go like nurse
can you touch my penis i'll see if i can
feel it that would have been the play
that would have been the plan
later on i'm just like i'll see that
blink 182 cover
but it's not the same like what you
watch online because bakersfield is all
male nurses
it's cool bro give it a whirl all the
older older ladies all the ladies
but it's weird because they're all that
stuff that comes later i'm like oh but
yeah
what was it oh yeah so so you woke up 10
9 8 and you go i'm paralyzed oh yeah
when did the word paralyzed like even
enter your mind like i can't feel my
hands i can't feel like what happened
can you move it everything after the
surgery and i was like oh shoot like i
can't move like even with with that i
couldn't even move more because even
without it before surgery i could like
move a little it was just straight up
just stuck
what's the feeling of paralyzed
uh let's see
well no feeling
the absence of it the stranger so you
sit on your hand it gets really numb you
can't move it that's a good analogy but
even numb is a feeling we all really
yeah that's strange i get it but it's
just a bigger stranger
yeah so just
everything numb and like it's funny
because like in your head you're like
move like
what the heck like just something and
just nothing something
cool
psychology part of it because there's a
you have to like accept the state of
paralysis right like
how was it going like oh [ __ ] i guess
this is the rest of my life it's it hit
me when uh
a lot of friends would visit like that
in the beginning when they visit because
they're like they're like like they're
all standing farm like
yo who's there like come close i can't
move that's like the biggest part i was
like you can't turn and just go oh yeah
yeah yeah or like you put the bed up
because i have no control that's right
that's what i'm like
okay because whatever configuration he's
laying in that's him so you have to like
go like you know yeah so that was that
was pretty interesting but yeah didn't
get any movement for like
four months so it's like kind of
just it was just breathing exercises
because today's video is brought to you
by upstart nothing is more discouraging
than paying towards your credit card but
barely making a dent in your debt that's
why upstart is here to help you pay off
your debt quickly so you can finally get
ahead upstart is the fast and easy way
to pay off your debt with a personal
loan all online whether you're paying
off credit cards consolidating high
interest debt or funding personal
expenses over half a million people have
used upstart to get one fixed monthly
payment upstart knows you're more than
just your credit score and is expanding
access to affordable credit unlike other
lenders upstart considers your income
and current employment to find you a
smarter rate for your loan with a five
minute rate check you could see your
rate up front
from loans between 1 000 to 50 000
and receive your funds as fast as one
business day after accepting your loan
find out how upstart can lower your
monthly payments today when you go to
upstart.com off the record that's
upstart.com off the record don't forget
to use our url so they know that we sent
you loan amounts will be determined
based off your credit income and certain
other information provided in your loan
application go to upstart.com
off the record and then what what was
like the first movement after four
months that like was like oh [ __ ] so
even before i got a little
yup
a little pump
that happens with the sp
with the with the connections not even
there so that's just like physiological
whoa weird one you're like that's a
dope-ass versatile man just like
like it moves on its own like it moves
and then you feel that move the sensory
it still goes on like it's because
biologically it'll still like get
aroused or up yeah but then like it's
weird because you see a pipe going
through it and you're like it should
hurt the catheter yeah whoa it doesn't
hurt but so i'm like oh oh and so
eventually so it goes from not even
moving it goes from like oh nothing hurt
nothing no feeling to all of a sudden
tingling i got really hot and cold and
all of a sudden that was like the first
i was like
ah oh wait
all right so let's go
my diggers and i love it you guys here
my dick hurts
what was the first thing i set out was
it really your penis because what they
got to do the catheter everything every
four hours right just to keep on
schedule so that was the first thing you
guys ever have a catheter
hundreds of penises they gotta handle
yeah yeah yeah
like thousands of them so the time that
they did it and i was like ow
whoa
whoa this is something new and i kind of
just like to deal with like oh okay okay
this is interesting they said nothing's
in return so i was like okay cool if
that hurts other things scared so like
the next day like a shower and i'm like
oh it's hella hot what the heck's wrong
with the the shower stuff here it's like
oh that's cool okay there's more pain
you can feel your skin's feeling now
it's like really hot never know
numbness then when hot cold and then
pain and eventually it's just like you
want to try and move it i was like
oh wow okay it was just something small
as that and i was like wow
okay busted the um how yeah was it was
it like a kill build big toe like a
moment or like how did you create the
connection like oh
like that i think i did to that movie i
saw a movie on like a tv or someone
brought a dvd and i was like
i ain't got nothing to do tv's off i was
like i'll still night person you know we
used to just hang out
with my person so i'm just like
i'm gonna just try it just keep moving
moving like for like hours because i
have nothing to do it's like
i could have sworn i saw a wiggle and
then i was like nurse like there's like
a button and like i
pushed it with my head hey hey
is it moving
like just dude just go to sleep dude
like it's like 2 a.m
like what are you doing it's like it's
like she's going to turn in
[Laughter]
uh
nah dude just go to sleep you're tired
it must have been a mental thing i was
like all right i'm gonna keep trying
i'm gonna say that [ __ ] trying to clean
your head yeah first finger was like hey
but
this is cool though
come on come on come on come on no
that's not the middle figure sleep dude
but he was he was a cold nurse because
he's he brought me food because hospital
food sucks and now so for months
i could only eat things at this that's
the consistency of applesauce and and
mashed potatoes so i lost like 70 i was
a big boy super skinny you were a big
boy i was over 200 pounds just eating
that stuff for like weird to think yeah
holy [ __ ] i was a big boy until a
hospital and he turned into [ __ ] kate
moss afterwards
just
eating that consistency i was like i'm
just not gonna eat food this is whack
everything just tastes like mashed
potatoes even now like mashed potatoes
like a you know it's a tier zero it's
not even up here anymore
sorry hometown sorry sorry guys sorry
sorry about it
yeah and then eventually i was like hey
now they're like oh your toe did move
like eventually like i said i was like
oh cool we checked the cameras we were
right
you were right was it paranormal yeah
you weren't that nurse
were you paralyzed from the neck down so
you're able to speak and like
and then so totally which was i think
the the
like the best thing that could happen
right i'd rather have like this intact
than all this stuff like that cause you
can communicate and stuff right which
late just crazy i can't believe kill
bill inspired you to start wiggling your
body parts i had nothing else to do
that's genius like 2 a.m it's like uncle
i'm just gonna watch a just a blank
screen on a tv good thing they showed
you kill bill and not like misery or
something
imagine we got two choices tj
misery
or or a [ __ ] million dollar baby yeah
oh
our beautiful mind oh no the nurses
in my head
what was the
major like when did you when were you
able to like sit up all the way so uh
during therapy they would set me up all
the time and then they would do like
balancing exercises so they set me up
and then let go like hold yourself and
then just like
holy [ __ ]
eventually like
eventually i could like slowly keep
myself up higher
and hold it longer and that's how like
even with the hands and like they're
just like force-feeding you and doing
things i'm like dude i can't do this
like my therapist is like we're playing
jenga today i was like
i'm gonna you want me playing jenga are
you serious like what the heck is going
like oh i want the arts and crafts i'm
like i'm down i i'm like i'm in here i'm
listening to you i don't have really
nothing better nothing else to do anyway
yeah i'll try everything like i went
through all their activities but if
someone's holding your hand or you're
trying to move and do it so they have
like a little skateboard type of thing
so this my left hand came in first so
they put it on the tech deck tech decks
so they kind of move it around moving
around and they try to this hand and
like this hand can't really do much
and then next there's like
like the so they put like straps on me
to keep me up and then they like loosen
it like if i keep myself up
boom and it's kind of like what was your
percentage of recovery
well
i think so after that while i was in the
first hospital in bakersfield they gave
me like only four four percent chance of
anything but it's bakersfield so they're
currently the mathematicians they're
wrong kern county thinks differently
yeah they told me 13 when they when they
were like
numbers all over the place they said 13
i was like why would you even [ __ ]
say a number then 13.
like he knew yeah
and it was changing so much too like
that's the initial one and then it
changed a lot and as i'm slowly getting
things back there's like oh cool like
we'll keep extending your stake because
with the whole like medical system
if they kind of like see your diagnosis
like oh cool he's gonna be here for four
months max and now he's gonna go home
because not much but every time
something else came up they're like oh
you keep keep extending extend but
that's more money for them right uh yeah
this place like me well well first of
all i have an insurance so like all like
child services and social security all
that kicked in which is nice because
like my parents were they were like
hard-working people
kind of yeah they're broken up at that
point but
because it's because of their record
that i was able to qualify for all that
and i'd have to pay for that because
that's hell expensive what do you think
you would have racked up like a million
dude easily even the helicopter ride
alone like
and then yeah cause they had to they
went over the hollywood sign and tours
you gotta pay for that cat they dropped
yeah that's the guy that created
herbalife
[Laughter]
first time in california tj let me show
you my tabletop that's not even cool
that's hawthorne right there how about
it huh awful
how about it
did is that that journey what inspired
you to become a therapist
it
occupational therapy was not on my list
because that was just like telling me to
do stuff i can't do
like jenga let's let's uh paint and
stuff my thing was like oh physical
therapy i know why physical therapy gets
all the love because it's always the
difference between the two so think of
it as so physical therapy you need the
movements to do things right so
occupational therapy is
taking the physical movements and do
stuff that gives you meaning so like in
your life it's mainly a movement stuff
but it's kind of like throughout your
day you're like if you're a father
you're a boss a ceo like but what what's
all the little things that that make
make the
your job you know like like pick my nose
or whatever yeah stuff like even picking
your nose i was like i just want people
to pick up my nose pick your nose like a
pro so it's like things like that to
give more context not just movement but
then even like i didn't know of
occupational therapy back then i was
just like
i gotta do that but as i was like
getting into like my health education
degree my undergrad i was like oh i
actually have a lot of first-hand
knowledge where it might it would work
but then actually so i just like oh let
me check out the therapy stuff
on the pt
i did uh some volunteering and i was
like yo this thing is kind of boring it
wasn't really like a exercise
that's all it was i'm like cool and then
i finally saw like the ot going and i'm
like
it makes sense
um occupation is the difference like
physical therapy is more like
enhancement and occupational therapy is
like rehabilitation
i mean they're both we're all they're
they're all safe they're all all the
same therapy more like gross motor
movement yeah more gross motion
occupations more like fine like what are
the what are the things that you do in
life does
we do is very like fine motor yeah so
that's like the stuff that gives you me
like you know being able to
type on your phone about masturbation is
that gross yeah it's part that's part of
adl
activity daily living and i actually
have to take a class i took a class it
was funny like you guys you want to
check out this class with other people
they'd show these like real really old
videos of like
70s 80s like it felt like soft core porn
[Laughter]
there's people disabled people like
going at it and i was like disabled
people going at it yeah because like
it's still possible like all this stuff
i'm like oh am i cool i can't even like
move everything you're already showing
me this stuff that's cool like it's like
just more stuff to like stab me with oh
i can't do this so right now because you
worked with so many kids
whenever the kids were like i can't do
it were you like i [ __ ] did it do it
yeah yeah yeah yeah i [ __ ] did it to
the kids 24
[ __ ] four
ryan's video said 13.
[Laughter]
yeah well you have 15.
i feel like uh there's some people that
felt like we weren't on the same team
because they're just very like you this
is what's happening you like diagnosing
me and i have other therapists who are
like we're on the same team so when i
see with the kids
i just support them as much like or even
with clients that i have that's in pain
like i support them right you try to act
more paralyzed so that they're that only
that's only for like movies disneyland
uh six flags disneyland
the first time we went to the front of
the line first time we went to knots
with him he was like check this out
what did you do what did you do
to the fun dude because as soon as they
saw him it was like the first time we
started going places and as soon as they
see them they're like there's like a
special [ __ ] thing like mickey mouse
comes out
most red carpet you're gonna be here
you start kicking the regular kids aside
vip tj that's how v.i.p it is mickey
comes out at nashville
the girls of the sparklers come out
you get everything parked like hey tj
here's your ride it's dole whips
welcome to matterhorn we didn't i still
didn't know what it would be but yeah
they just they do it before he even says
anything because uh because while i was
at the hospital we had like special like
groups that was like oh like we're gonna
take you out to places like
i could do all this stuff like yeah you
just gotta ask or they know so by the
time i was out i was like you'll have
all this ammo we could just
everywhere even parking he just goes
just put this on your mirror yeah
share it or even like movie theaters i'm
like oh cool batman was opening me again
i go up hi
i just extend my cane that i am like all
right all my friends are right here
they're like oh you're blind
[Laughter]
batman
oh you're blind
wrong king
every once in a while i gotta pull that
trick because sometimes they're like oh
like oh you're using the power card i'm
like i put it back and just like all
right i'm gonna walk even more messed up
and then the person just goes
pulled me over and they're like hey what
you doing i'm like is that is that yours
i'm like
yeah
okay like prove it you know he's like
okay okay and then he sees me park and
then he starts walking like all right
and he's like have a good day sir
thanks thanks like what am i not
supposed to am i supposed to drive a
crappy van that's like all like nasty or
something like that because my yeah
because it's so cool it's just like a
regular just like you know not regular
but like a modified car i know yeah so
it's like well i can't drive nice things
or have nice things so if i asked you
that yeah that's the idea i had a couple
of like instances of that where like
they kind of like pulled me over like
what you're doing like one time i was uh
this was like kind of where it's like
one time i pulled over because i had to
pee and i can't control my bladder as
well so it's like oh i have bottles
sometimes my car is like cool i'll pull
or pee some more i'm like like why you
ask me questions like sweating so it
looks like probably i did something
wrong like what's going on i'm just
trying to pee officer well the exit's
right there it's like i couldn't make
the exit i have a disability huh
okay
get the [ __ ] out of the car
yeah
if you're if you're not lying just pee
and i was like this better be pissed
you want to watch me
like there's times that's like one
instance and i was like did this really
happen and i was like
man you made me mess up my nice pants
like i just wanted to show you you can't
pee in a bottle in your own car uh i
don't know is that illegal
um it's illegal but maybe they just
don't believe that's what you're doing
yeah oh i see i said that's kind of
weird things like that you're not like
the [ __ ] in your car
yeah you can't do that yeah so you
probably can't whip your dick out oh but
you're not a lot of [ __ ] car where
where
i think i asked like anywhere i think
anywhere except your garage
tj now you just um you work with kids at
the hospital and and then you help them
or like is it injured kids or people or
so right now during the week like a
part-time ish i found a really good boss
that lets me like do a bunch of side
stuff so i work with kids at school
so get them to be the best at being a
student so occupational therapy so like
what their stages in life so as a kids
like
getting them to be the best kid and
student so like
sensory things a lot of
fine motor handwriting just being able
to navigate classes how do how do a lot
of these kids get get there they're just
a lot of the they're just diagnosed i
mean a lot of there's like either
there's like a physical limitation
cognitive
limitation mental so there's there's
always something that's already like
underlying so work with that and on the
side i mean i was like juggling school
and question stuff just helping you guys
for a long time and now i work with the
dancers because it kind of just like
transitioned over with like just taking
care of them and then seeing them at
being at the top quest being at the top
and like
there's no really like health care for
you guys and that kind of yeah dancers
have like the worst self-care as far as
like maintenance for like your body and
beating it up all damn day yeah yeah and
it's like that that turned a switch in
my head like oh like i want to give back
to the community where i was i was part
of like supporting like anthony and all
the homies like yeah like which was cool
because you when you first when we first
met you just treated me like it's like
nothing like nothing ever happened or
just as as me because that's like i only
felt that from like ryan harris and a
couple of the friends so it's kind of
well everyone treated you like some oh
we got to be sensitive with the handicap
man like is that what they did no no
actually it's it's funny because right
now as i'm like sitting still he's like
no actually they're a little bit like
that
that's pretty good
no because i got but i'm saying still
it's very like i don't have like a big
visual disability yeah but it's like
once i start walking they're like oh are
you okay and it's like oh yeah once she
starts twerking it looks way off
so i like still got cakes but
it was like a lot of times it was at
your house so it was like not a lot of
movement stuff and i guess it just i
don't know what it was but you're just
chilling man just chilling he talks you
behind your back that's why
he's different
he says your glasses aren't even
prescription that's what he says i can't
move that fast it's okay hey tell them
about your modeling stuff you're doing
now oh [ __ ] yeah so a couple of years
ago 2019 so zappos have this has this
team called zappos adaptive
uh which they've been helping people
helping people in the disability
community like find better products one
time they just kind of posted like hey
we're looking for uh models with
disabilities and i was like
you know my life's been kind of like not
like you know traditionally traditional
like i'mma apply like hey you guys
looking for asian model dude
boom and all of a sudden i was like oh
[ __ ] this is real like
doing a runway and everything so
you did it
let's go 2019 in vegas and then like uh
rj mitty he's the he was like the guy
with cp on breaking bad was our host
and then
this past week i did the la premiere
because it was in vegas they did the new
york fashion show and now like it's like
a movement where they know that there's
a big market for like adaptive clothing
not even for like disabilities but
disability is kind of like as a spectrum
where we're all gonna encounter
disability just because as you grow
older there's less stuff you could do so
now that people know
like there's a big market so the zappos
team got even bigger with bigger
sponsors and we did a la fashion show
and i also get to be part of it again i
was like that's cool hey you guys need
another asian guy again because i am
down like asian disabled just count me
in like yeah we need your girls like oh
tight
they made those i saw they had like
shoes where like you don't even think of
this stuff you don't think how hard it
is to put a shoe on you talk about the
nike ones yeah i heard the controversy
there though yeah they're like sneaker
heads are just copping them left and
right in my eyes oh for real oh
because did you guys see
actually it's like genius like they're
they're pyramid and you just step your
foot on and it clicks the heel back yeah
yeah but all these sneaker heads bought
them up here it's kind of yeah
yeah it's like yeah it was more like
marketing i feel like or like just like
feel good and there's a lot of other
companies trying more but yeah they're
fake
yeah yeah why would they do limited
edition yeah that's so
exclusive release
if regular people taking l's like our
community is taking like doubles
yeah [ __ ] the sneaker app
so yeah so i got to be part of that uh
i've been i've just been always into
tech so i'm actually doing collaborating
with
like microsoft and so whoa
that's so cool
huh right now like taking care of the
breaking scene right now with it getting
into the olympics
just a collaborat i was able to connect
with other people that came from the
dance scene and saw like they're gonna
need this healthcare support because
there's nothing for breakers at least
going in or nothing for dancers on top
of that but breaking was like where we
originated from yeah so it's kind of
getting there like hey like all the
stuff in in the traditional sports it
works so like it's from montebello by
the way too
hey monterey park
which is funny that people most times
like you're not from montebello and i
tell them like this there's cross
streets my friends lived in they're like
what i'm like
i know hendrix and you know whittier
what's the alberto's menu
that's not how berto is there did i
think there's no asians in montebello or
something well i always hung out on like
the south side so like when you like
like you went to sheriff washington
uh couple kept you only no but then sure
is you know montebello yeah the same say
yeah but i went to like the the non like
asian school montebello on the south
side oh yeah yeah
so i was like always like
me and like like six other asian people
were like the only ones there
so kind of like it's funny because the
whole like trade trajectory of stuff it
was never like it was just always like
odd man out or like kind of just being
who i am and eventually that's what it's
like that's what i'm doing now just
being the fullest of me rather than just
playing up to stuff did that help you
with your whole identity and stuff yeah
like always kind of being the odd man
out so it's just easier to just
not focus on what the rest of everyone
else is doing yeah because it was from
the beginning it was like always like
the one the one asian kid in class and
it's very like
so it was in
being in all these different situations
always it's kind of been very similar so
there hasn't been anything like on the
ordinary it's like all right cool it's
cool it's like for me it's very like it
doesn't asian nowadays it didn't matter
because i was just already hanging out
it's funny because it was after my
accident i was like the most asian
friends i got after because prior to
that it was all like like mexican like
armenian like everything else besides
asian plumber my mom's just like
you can get no asian girl and that's a
that's a whole different story man i
think i think you know you know what
though if we're if we're gonna do hot
seat and all those other stuff with them
stay tuned for that dude
[Music]
[Music]
you